[Music]
Nicola jokic making history bam out of
Bio had a big game three as well Jimmy
Butler got off to a fast start 10 points
in the first quarter seemed like he was
setting the tone Miami takes the early
lead but speaking of setting the tone
seat Nicoli jokic Jamal Murray the
dynamic duo absolutely doing that I mean
not only were they doing it but they
were doing it well
Queens on him
I mean I mean the Joker and Murray not
only you know their their pick and roll
action their ability to play the pass
and drop dimes I mean they control the
game tonight offensively as well as
defensively I mean so you think the only
thing Zeke and Jamal is that the zone is
the only thing that could have slowed
them down a little bit more tonight I I
don't
I thought the way
the winner for the zone you know the way
Joker was getting the ball
at the foul line and Not only was he
pinning that guard at the foul line then
they would swing it down to the corner
and he was just rolling right to the
middle 22 and 17 for bam Jamal Murray
had three threes in the first half and
the Nuggets really tough to beat when he
does that Jamal yes he is he's the head
of this next going wise when he gets to
go and he gives her team confidence he
gets rolling and then his picker poison
at that point
9-1 this postseason when he hits three
or more threes he had 20 in the first
half AG are you with me no one stopped
the ball there Kenny no one stopped the
ball however
I think just Denver again make it good
to basketball decisions that's a
unbelievable basketball decision right
there to make a bounce pass instead of
the chest pass then in the lane you get
it get it back finish it in the lane
they just made great basketball
decisions the whole night
in that space you were talking about
Zeke just shooting over the cone
the student over to Cone but again his
his ability to position himself to get
into those open spots knock down threes
and then they're transition defense you
know just getting out on the break you
know Denver Denver was good tonight they
were good in All Phases of the game
that's a tough shot that wasn't even a
floater that was like a jump shot from
12 feet that's tough yeah and then on
the Move here's the ground getting
physical into the lane using his
physicality six foot seven
215 pounds of a freight train I mean you
pointed that out when he left this set
you kind of look at him overpowering
Jimmy Butler you go oh yeah yeah he's
the same size size but then he's three
inches taller oh my goodness
what do you do with that Kenny
Ewing and you hope that they can guard
it well all those guys you just
mentioned
the greatest centers of all time have
never put up this stat line 32 points 21
rebounds 10 assists in fact nobody in
finals history has done that the only
guys do it at NBA history in the
playoffs Wilt and Kareem they did it one
time each this might bring the center
back because okay you know now you have
to contend with a center yeah like a
real one so you now you know where bam
is a great power forward that's playing
Center so now if you want to beat the
Denver Nuggets you better have size and
athleticism
and you have to be at least seven feet
to guard a guy like that so it's going
to be interesting to see what people do
in the future because even if they don't
win this in Miami wins the NBA
Championship you know in the west you
have to contend with the Joker
and and then the East right you got to
deal with MB and be honest so when you
talk about the big men coming back at
the center position the way they're
planning and they're all playing it
differently like Joker's plays different
than embiid and he plays different than
Giannis right so you got three seven
Footers playing differently and those
been the last three MVPs of the league
Dwight Howard on standby the center
coming back well you know we're talking
about I mean we're talking about young
centers honestly but the guys who like
that are coming back because as much as
Joker shoots the three
he punishes you yeah like if you put a
if you do that NBA Vogue switch that a
switch everything on the perimeter so
here's the point guard he's set to pick
and the point guards guarding your
Center he does not float to the
three-point line he backs you in all the
way in the basket like your little
brother and he plays like you your
little brother serious Jimmy you're my
little brother in the backyard and I'm
not gonna allow you to guard me and then
you put bam on you I can shoot this I
can shoot the mid-range then I'm gonna
pass but I am never staying on the
perimeter when I have a guard guarding
me look at me little brother Kevin Love
is a power forward ladies and gentlemen
he is not a sinner and that is the
difference between him and everyone else
in the league right now everyone does
the too little celebration Nicole jokic
just does that to Defenders all the time
just look at how the Miami Heat finished
the pass two games as compared to this
one yeah negative one in this one as
opposed to plus 10 in game one plus 11
in game two but Jamal he was talking
about points of the paint looking for
the numbers uh 60-34 and you had him you
would have went up there be like 60-34
coach what's interesting to me though is
after both losses both coaches were like
it was correctable things it was effort
we got all Hustle
they both think they can win this series
because of those little small things
they both can correct and control and
that's what's really interesting hearing
him hearing coach Malone last game is
things they think are correctable and I
think we're in for a great series
because of that they both believe they
have the team you believe that about if
I believe it or not no I'm just asking
as an analyst and a great player I want
to know do you believe that they're
correctable they're correctable but I'm
not sure it's enough I really believe
Denver is a higher level of Miami they
have the same makeup they have the same
culture they have the same belief system
play Fast play together play the right
way play hard leave no possessions
wasted you know what I like about both
of them and not this is
and I got this actually watching the
Pistons growing up and we used I used to
use this analogy so if you can hold my
mic I said there's a never if you watch
Denver and you watch Miami there's never
there's never got Jalen Rose the great
the great Jalen Rose
and he's acting now he's in bmf2 Jay's
doing everything
yeah you're not getting paid to be on
our network but uh but what I was going
to say is like I love those teams
because you never see a guy do this to
another player
that's my pet peeve your hands can't be
cups when you're talking to me yeah
because that brings negative energy
to back to me so if I'm here and you and
I'm and if I do this to you like I
didn't see you
I'm gonna if you go hey look I'm like I
didn't see you I'm coming at you with a
different energy and that's what that
team not when you talk about culture you
never see the cup hands no you never see
it any negative energy comes from their
coaches when they're correcting right
right it doesn't come from their players
like you said it doesn't come from oh
man you miss me no this that's because
no you got to get that rebound will make
me never pass you the ball ever like I'm
ever like I don't even see him I'll see
you bro like you you giving me cup hands
like no you're not getting it well I I
would say this when you when you talk
about effort right and Coach Malone was
like we didn't give effort you know
after the last game and what his team
showed up and did is they gave effort
and where did it show up showed up in
terms of rebounds right 58 to 33. I mean
that's dominance on the glass not only
is it dominance on the glass but those
are the things that just wear the
opponent down and so physicality they
talked about physicality they talked
about effort they talk about energy G
those are things that the coach can
bring out of you right and and those are
things that the coach can point out like
hey hold your account you didn't bring
the effort tonight and then the players
responded and said okay Coach here's the
effort 58-33 and now supposed to is
saying hey
we got we got out physical and Coach is
saying here's the effort here's the win
yes give that effort you'll win the game
well when Zeke said the numbers I
thought you were doing Joker's numbers
you're like 58 33 50 something like that
his numbers are Nicola jokes